maladies inflammatoires articulaires
maladies inflammatoires intestinales
maladies respiratoires aiguës et
chroniques cancérologie dermatologie et
un tas d'autres cas où les médecins
doivent prescrire de la cortisone
médicaments souvent de premier recours
et irremplaçable les patients en ont
besoin madame la ministre
depuis quelques semaines nous assistons
à une décroissance des stocks de
cortisone orale comme injectables et
nous arrivons aujourd'hui à une
véritable pénurie dans les officines qui
comptera les patients se livrer à une
surréaliste chasse au trésor pouvez vous
nous expliquer précisément comment cette
situation incroyable et inacceptable ce
produit est pourquoi elle n'a pas été
aussi anticipé est bien plus en amont et
pouvez vous nous faire un point de
situation pour vous répondre la parole
est à la secrétaire d'état auprès de la
ministre des solidarités la santé
christophe duboscq n'aime le ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs sénateurs monsieur le sénateur
vous nous interroger sur les inquiétude
exprimée ces dernières semaines par des
patients par des patients et des
médecins en rencontrant des difficultés
pour s'approvisionner en corticoïdes
nous tenons tout d'abord à vous rassurer
les agences du médicament landsem a
écarté jeudi dernier tout risque de
pénurie pour les corticoïdes
cette information n'est pas le fruit
d'un heureux hasard mais d'une action
volontariste des autorités sanitaires
en effet dès que l'on sème a été
informée début mai des tensions
d'approvisionnement de corticoïdes
elle a immédiatement convoqué les
fabricants afin qu'il prenne toutes les
mesures nécessaires pour assurer l'accès
à ces médicaments pour les patients dans
les plus brefs délais cela se traduit
par la mobilisation par les fabricants
de stocks permettant de garantir la
couverture des besoins des patients
lancet mais également régulièrement
échangé avec les représentants
d'associations de patients et les
professionnels de santé pour partager
des informations à sa disposition ne
connaissons nous reconnaissons qu'il y a
été difficile en effet ça peut être
encore le cas pour certains patients aux
professionnels de santé de se procurer
facilement des corticoïdes par voie
orale ou injectable le retour à une
disponibilité normal de ces médicaments
dans les pharmacies d'officine
hospitalière est attendue d'ici la fin
du mois de juin
d'ici là landes sommes maintient son
dispositif de suivi renforcé et un
tableau des disponibilités des
différentes spécialités par dosage et
publiques et consultables sur leur site
nous faisons le choix d'une gestion
transparente de ces dossiers
mais si les autorités n'ont pas tardé à
réagir élan demeure pas moins que la
situation actuelle en termes de rupture
de médicaments n'est pas acceptable pour
les français et pour cela la ministre
des solidarités de la santé agnès buzyn
présentera dans quelques jours un plan
d'action notamment par mais évitant la
pénurie des médicaments et avoir une
visibilité sur la gestion des stocks
je vous remercie je rappe 1 madame la
ministre
c'est la réponse que nous lisons dans la
presse mais sur le terrain croyez moi
c'est tout à fait différent
madame la mini je suis médecin et les
prescriptions que je fais encore de
cortisone ne sont pas honorés
aujourd'hui les patients du mal à en
trouver c'est une certitude donc acté le
maintenant l'anticipation elle a été
très mauvaise sur le sujet et maintenant
les causes de ce fait pourquoi
aujourd'hui arrive-t-on à des ruptures
de stock dans les médicaments et les
thérapeutiques qui sont proposés tout
simplement parce qu'on gère une médecine
à bas coût et la pénurie en est la
variable d'ajustement donc remédier à
cela et très vite car sinon nous aurons
des soucis sanitaires énorme merci
[Applaudissements]